the Chilean startup scene is looking for
homegrown solutions to adapt to a
changing environment
lndia tooten cuenta con que cambio cream
at ego until a al me no effect ow la
condición natural de optician de agua
Luis any Eau de pasando
yes agua de calidad general I went to
him for Manitoulin so actor Pino figured
out how to make water from air with the
touch of a button
Hector made a fortune as an engineer but
now works full-time on his fresh water
system what propelled you to think of
this project l'enfer my Amiga yeah Dena
Segundo Malcolm he need Oh a loaf when
yoni investigan donate a mundo and
elastin Ohia vemos Canada no Jamila dad
caso de listen tanky son Marino's
Debussy baba booey figga Kalia yes a
dengue appropiate an un mundo muy into t
al-assad ya lo n formato doméstico bar a
gimme hug we're addicts eres a s agua
que le man to ear Allah so an asana to
use this machine at home yes ok and and
your daughter uses this every day
ah they complete my family when Aniyah
ECC at the Annie okay Damon Arnold mad
Hector sees this technology having uses
far beyond his family his freshwater
machine feeds off humidity in the air it
pulls in water particles through a vent
and then basically forms a rain cloud
inside the machine a series of filters
purify the water collected and then
pristine h2o flows out of the faucet
[Music]
so I can drink it yeah your baby will
have eternity it's not problem
we delicioso highlight it right now one
magic water machine cost about sixteen
hundred bucks but he wants to shrink the
price and its size to something like a
backpack as he perfects the design he's
installed his machines in chillies dry
north locate Amazon Dora
Tommo million Doel impacto por que una
cosa int'l a la tecnología pero lo otro
es ser kwai no Scipio
well fue la consecuencia yes impacto
sociologic oh yay oh no miko' LK Tom Oh
Millie endo para poder nosotros calar
hace otro país Emoto - bueno resultado
[Music]